kammer urteil des verfassungsgerichts in
karlsruhe und es geht um keine geringere
als ex kanzlerin angela merkel kurzer
rückblick anfang 2020 dafür half die afg
erstmals mit ihren stimmen einem
ministerpräsidenten ins amt es waren
thüringen ex kanzlerin merkel nannte den
vorgang unverzeihlich dass müsse
rückgängig gemacht werden die fdp regte
daraufhin klage ja und nun hat das
verfassungsgericht also sein urteil
gesprochen und der afg recht gegeben es
ist der grösste schuss den angela merkel
im nachgang zu ihrer kanzlerschaft
gefangen hat eine der wirklich brachial
ssten verfassungsrechtlichen übertritte
wird ihr hier amtlich bescheinigt vom
höchsten gericht